[Musik]
das podcast ist brought you the munich
ich habe ein bisschen erkältung also ich
hoffe dass meine stimme für die eine
stunde reicht dann haben wir alle
feierabend so also jetzt geht es
wirklich zur sache
letzte woche hat unser thema eingeführt
diese woche werde ich die größte finde
so viel der philosophin der europäischen
sprachen nämlich philosophinnen bis zur
zeit von platon und hat es deutlich es
eigentlich bis zum vierten jahrhundert
vor christus und das da wird in erster
linie über die targo rinnen gehen und
dann werden wir eine völlig offen ist
vielleicht übertrieben aber eigentlich
figuren bestreiten namens aspasia die
bei plattform nun anderswo auftaucht das
heißt man könnte sagen wir betrachten
hier die hintergründe zur frauen
betrachtung bei platten des ortes
andererseits werden wir auch schon hier
heute sehen das ein thema das ich öfter
betonen werde im laufe der vorlesung
serie nämlich dass wir diese frauen
nichts die ich letzte woche schon gesagt
habe dass wir diese weibliche
denkerinnen nicht einfach pauschal
betrachten sollen sondern immer einen
zusammenhang und bedingungen und
hintergrund jeder einzelnen figuren
überlegen und nachdenken
zuerst aber wollte ich etwas zu den
allgemeinen bedingungen der frauen in
der antike war es natürlich ein sehr
großes thema ist und noch dazu ein thema
wo ich überhaupt kein experte denn es
gibt natürlich forscher die die ganze
karriere diesem thema widmen
und schließlich muss man nicht vergessen
kann simpson prozent der bevölkerung
also wirklich um die frage nach
nachzuforschen wie war es für frauen in
der antike zu beantworten würden wir
viel mehr als eine vorlesungsreihe
brauchen also jetzt werde ich nur
wirklich punktuell ein paar sachen sang
vor allem staates fragen in athen war es
natürlich besonders relevant ist für uns
wegen unserer interesse an philosophie
können sie mich alle können übrigens
auch helfen uns nicht leisten das ist
schlecht
so können sie sich jetzt passen oder was
sagen sie was sagen die anderen
wahrscheinlich
er hat vielleicht liegt es an das
publikum direkt erstellt das publikum
nach
sie sind den zehn minuten ruhig ok also
habe er gedacht haben die leute die ganz
hinten sitzen im syker schon oder
sie wirken natürlich waren die
bedingungen für fragen in der antike
ähnlich wie die bedingungen für frauen
jetzt sehr unterschiedlich und es kann
sehr darauf an wo man gelebt hat und wer
mann war
man kann die bedingung für eine arme
frau in der antike nichts mit bedingung
für eine einer reichen frau in der
gleichen stadt zwei davon eine arme frau
in athen mit einem gleichen frau in
schwarzer oder im römischen reich es
bekanntlich waren die war die situation
für frauen in athen schlechter als die
situation ins weiter es ist sehr
berühmtes dass die sparte frauen
möglichkeiten hatten die diatonische
frauen nicht hatten und das diatonische
frauen vielmehr an dem haushalt gebunden
worden
manche die sich fragen wie würden wir
das wissen aus der archäologie oder wie
die und das eine gute frage
da kenne ich mich vielleicht zu finden
das alle ausführliche antwort zu geben
aber wir haben mag hier relevante
quellen zum beispiel die gesetze solons
so lang war der
fast mythisch sehr berühmter gesetzgeber
von athen und in seinem gesetz erhalten
sind gibt es manche punkte die frauen
betreffen in athen und auch im spot
wollen mädchen mindestens manchmal
ausgebildet also das heißt dass sie die
die berühmte musiker ausbildung bekommen
haben die bei platon in der politik und
in der politik des dort ließ besprechen
wird besprochen wird
das heißt sie hätten lesen und schreiben
lernen und auch ein bisschen über musik
und gedichte also homer j
das würde natürlich nur die obere
schicht betreffen
aber das betrifft auch nur die optische
der männer untere schicht für den magic
würden natürlich nicht ausgebildet haben
wesen nicht gelernt und das gilt
natürlich für was die ganze die ganze
vormoderne geschichte und das wird
vielleicht nicht vergessen das würden
wir hier über die gelegenheiten die
frauen oder die möglichkeiten die frauen
zugänglich waren
und wenn wir das mit der nennt der
möglichkeiten die den männern zugänglich
waren
wir vergleichen eigentlich die
situationen der aristokratischen frauen
mit der situation der aristokratischen
männern zb sofort wo ich sage wir
sprechen hier von leute die über
schreiben schweige davon philosophie
treiben natürlich sind wir bei der ganz
oberen schicht okay und deswegen soll
man nicht vergessen also hauptsächlich
die sp die frage ist wie weiß frau in
der antike zu sein
antwort meines bauern
veit wurde wir haben wir dass man es
abschreiben sollte okay so trotzdem war
es möglich in manchen fällen für mädchen
ausgebildet zu werden das heißt dass wir
privatisiert sind privatisierte mädchen
in manchen fällen haben die mindestens
lesen und schreiben könnten und dass es
natürlich die voraussetzung dass sie für
solche schriften verfassen
ob sie wirklich wieder solche schriften
verfasst haben
es wird eine abfrage der heutigen
vorlesung seien vor allem in athen aber
im allgemeinen auch in der römischen
welt waren frauen sehr stark an den
haushalt zu prüfen und das wird für uns
heute sehr wichtig sein
thematisch will ich hin sie sind an dem
bus oder mit dem bus dem haushalts sehr
identifiziert und in manchen fällen
dürfen nicht einmal das haus verlassen
oder nur das haus verlassen und ganz
eigenen bedingungen zb nur mit dem mann
oder nur mit männlichen mitgliedern des
haushaltes natürlich an die regeln die
wir jetzt zum beispiel nach afghanistan
wo sowas finden
deswegen habe ich glaube ich habe letzte
woche gesagt dass die lage für frauen in
der antike manchmal an die lage unter
den taliban als das was ich gemeint habe
oder finden auch regelungen dass sie das
haus nicht in der nacht verlassen dürfen
weil es zu gefährlich ist wahrscheinlich
sie sind frauen das fahren sind werden
sehr oft durch oder von der perspektive
gesehen dass sie hauptsächlich dafür
zuständig sind ein haushalt zu führen
und selbst others oth ließ keinen sehr
erfahren
freundliche autor wie die nächste woche
hin werden selbst alles so mies sagt es
gibt manche aufgaben die der frau
zugeschrieben werden also das heißt der
mann satt du frau übernimmt diese
aufgaben sonst bin ich für alles
zuständig er leider sagt ja eigentlich
nicht was er damit meint aber sachen wie
kindererziehung wahrscheinlich sklaven
behandeln mindestens die weibliche
sklavinnen also die haus die hausfrau
herum weil dafür zuständiges zu schauen
dass dies klappt ist klar denn dann ihre
aufgabe erfüllt haben und mein
lieblingsbeispiel es gibt einen text wo
wir erfahren dass ein gutes haus oder
gus haushalt besteht darin dass die
aufgabe des mannes des ehemannes die
aufgabe der ehefrau ausgleicht weil der
mann das geld rein bringt und die
ehefrau gibt es geld aus
also man muss das natürlich übertrieben
aber man sieht dass sie dafür zuständig
waren wahrscheinlich dass gegen essen da
war oder was
was für essen vorhanden sein sollte
vielleicht wirbel und so weiter und
natürlich denken sie wahrscheinlich das
klingt alles ganz schlecht aber das ist
natürlich auch eine art kraft wurde
macht was plan dadurch hatten und vor
allem und das wird für uns sehr wichtig
seien heute das ist eine aufgabe die man
schlecht oder gut erfüllen kann je
nachdem ob man clever ist oder wie wir
öfter sehen werden je nachdem ob man die
tugend besitzt man könnte sogar sagen
und wir werden das jetzt wäre denn
mehrmals sehen dass gesagt wird du dass
der mann dafür zuständig ist die stadt
die police zu füllen
ähnliche weise ist die frau dafür ist
zuständig das haushalt zu führen
sie ist der könig im haus bis zu einer
gewissen grade natürlich letzten endes
ist es der mann der ehemann der dafür
zuständig ist das haus zu führen also
weil jeder haus jeder hausherr das
irgendwie ein geschäftsmann und übrigens
am vielleicht sollte ich auch sagen dass
sie vielleicht wahrscheinlich haben sie
die falsche idee jetzt im kopf wenn ich
über ein haushaltsstreit was ich
eigentlich damit meine vor allem in der
römischen römischen reich aber auch für
unsere griechen
nicht nur ein kleines haus anfang eines
haus denken aber er ist so was vor allem
bei den römern wie eine villa mit felder
und um es eigentlich ein großer haken
und so es wirklich ein geschäft zu
bezahlen
moment ich muss warum sind sie mich
jetzt hören übrigens an
und in diesem sinne werden frauen
manchmal als partner des ehemannes
vorgestellt also wenn sie zu sagen
zusammenarbeiten und harmonisch
miteinander umgehen und dann ist das
haus erfolgreich genau wie wenn all die
schichten in einer stadt
zusammenarbeiten ist die stadt
erfolgreich
gibt es möglichkeiten für frauen
außerhalb diese diesem kontext nicht es
die erwartung war dass frauen schon nach
der adoleszenz oder werdende der erste
trainer lizenz heiraten würden
und deswegen war das der also
erwartungsgemäß war dass die situation
der frauen tätig waren
natürlich gibt es vor allem später in
der römischen zeit ausnahmen so frauen
sogar politische macht ausüben weil sie
zum beispiel die mutter eines königs
songs sind also nehmen wir an der könig
der imperator stirbt und der nächste
kaiser ist noch drei jahre alt die frage
ist wer übernimmt dann die tägliche
regieren
regierung antwort manchmal die mutter ab
und zu
natürlich gibt es auch imperator innen
warm in der gesamtemission geschichte
das werden wir später besprechen
aber es ist also zu sagen dass das eine
ausnahme ist ist natürlich sehr gute
trieb also hauptsächlich haben wir es
selbst in der demokratischen geschichte
haben wir hauptsächlich damit zu tun
dass wir hausherren haben
allerdings gibt es dann möglichkeiten
für frauen an
für solche aktivitäten damit gebunden zu
sein
oder an die aktivitäten die an für das
sie erinnern und das erste beispiel ist
wahrscheinlich die solistische bewegung
die werde jetzt ein bisschen
ausführlicher was über die sophisten
sein weil es für als ballsicher relevant
ist
das ist vielleicht manche von ihnen
schon sehr gut bekannt aber dann können
sie ein paar minuten von saas irgendwas
zu räumen wie wir gerade gehört zu einem
wovon träumt die weibliche katze vom
muskelkater
ja
das war schon der höhepunkt der heutigen
quali ist und dieser festen heißt
natürlich der weise also jemand der die
die weisheit besitzt und die sophisten
waren also man könnte vielleicht
erwarten dass sie irgendwie philosophen
wagen also die haben weisheit uns
verständnis dieses gottes ist sehr von
klar es wird sehr von platon bestimmt
bei platon betrachtet diese wissen als
gegner und soll und sogar als figuren
die er für das vieh entgegengesetzt sind
warum weil sie seiner meinung nach nicht
wirklich an die wahrheit und an
philosophische forschung denken in der
ersten linie sondern an überzeugungen
weil sie vor allem experte für rhetorik
sind und man kann das ist nicht ganz
unrecht ding zu wissen gegenüber weil
die sophisten vorwiegend brot verdient
haben dadurch dass sie junge männer
unterrichtet haben oder ausgebildet
haben gute reden zu halten vor dem volk
und da sieht man sofort dass erst eine
starke verbindung besteht zwischen diese
dieser touristischen bewegung und die
demokratie die wir natürlich sehr mit
athen verbinden
es gab zu wissen anderswo in
griechenland aber vor allem verbinden
wir diese wissen mit athen weil in athen
ist sehr wichtig war
ob man eine rede halten konnte wodurch
man da den demos über ziele also das
volk überzeugen konnte irgendwas zu tun
also und dann haben wir berühmte
solisten die zum beispiel pro tages
gorgas hyypiäs die in platons dialogen
auftauchen
es gibt mehrere dialogen die sogar nach
so festen genannt werden einschließlich
diese drei die schon erwähnt habe
timos und es gibt andere ferne
es gibt auch einen dialog über den über
diesen begriff so ist es wohl die es
gibt keinen so ist anwesend in die bei
dieser bei diesen dialog aber die
versuchen herauszufinden was genau ein
so frisst ausmacht also wie man das
definieren kann und wie das so ist mit
der mit dem film so verwandt ist oder
was unterscheidet die die zwei
voneinander auf jeden fall gab es so
fest
also das heißt weibliche figuren die
bekannt dafür dass sie sehr gut reden
konnten und wir haben ein haupt beispiel
das ist es was basia die wir später
näher kennenlernen werden
und angeblich hat sie so thies die
retter beigebracht
diese feststellung kommt bei platten vor
werden wir erst später gesperrt
also von daher könnten wir vermuten dass
es möglichkeiten gegeben haben müssen
für frauen auch so sagen außerhalb des
hauses tätig zu sein vielleicht reden zu
halten oder mindestens reden redekunst
zu lernen und auch zu lernen
übrigens haben sie ein händler es sind
zum glück hatte ich noch 1 ok also das
ist die solistische bewegung und frauen
waren 11 mindestens ein bisschen mit
beteiligt dann breite und im allgemeinen
können wir sagen dass meine
philosophische bewegungen in der antike
frauen zugelassen haben
zum beispiel gab es frauen bei den
zyniker bei den serien und bei anderen
hessischen schulen die historiker sind
sogar dafür bekannt dass sie lernt dass
frauen auch für das sortieren können und
auf die tugend erwerben können und hier
ist es wichtig zu bemerken dass wir
vorsichtig sein müssen denn wir über
philosophie und philosophen und innen
sprachen jemand hat mich erst letzte
woche gefragt ob ich philosophie
definieren konnte ja gesagt auf keinen
fall ein grund dafür ist dass wir immer
vorsichtig sein müssen was philosophie
in einem bestimmten kultur bedeutet zum
beispiel werden wir sehen das auch in
drei wochen werden wir sehen dass wir
auch über indische philosophinnen
sprechen können obwohl in antiken in
denen man natürlich das wortlose freenet
hatte also man kann sogar überlegen ob
philosophie was philosophie ist in der
abwesenheit des gottes oder sophie aber
in diesem fall haben
kultur die des wortführers wie erfunden
hat und sie verwenden dieses wollten
nicht unbedingt in der art und weise wie
wir das verwenden
paradebeispiel es gibt grabsteine in der
antike wo die noch erhalten sind und wo
die inschriften da darf der nd nd
mannschaft stets so und so liegt hier
ein philosoph oder eine philosophie und
das kommt nicht häufig vor
und da könnte man denken mein gott es
gab tausende philosophen und wovon die
werke nicht erhalten sind aber dass es
wäre irreführend wie die anderen bands
in einem artikel bemerkt hat mehrere
jahre hat er hat er darauf aufmerksam
gemacht denn wenn es darin die dieser
entsteht so ein philosoph das heißt
wahrscheinlich nur dass der mann oder
die frau sehr tugendhaft war also sehr
gut gelebt hat die toten so ausgeführt
haben in den läden stehen
später sehen das auch die christliche
tradition viel leistet das wort
philosophie mit dieser beute bedeutung
her genommen hat also asketische männer
und frauen würden oft als philosophen
und philosophinnen geschrieben sogar
wird die wahre lage des christentums
selbst das wirklich manchmal als
philosophie verschrieben
ohne natürlich natürlich ohne dann jetzt
zu bedeuten dass das irgendwie besonders
nation lsg im gegensatz zur religion
oder so was das heißt nur so was die
durch christentum kann man weisheits
erlangen und philosophie ist natürlich
die mulde für die weisheit deswegen
christ des jesus christus der beste
philosophie der uns alle durch die
philosophie an die wahrheit sieht wie
auch immer also dieses worte philosophie
wird sehr sehr unterschiedlich
wahrgenommen natürlich hat das wort
manchmal die engere bedeutung womit wir
eher zu hause und zu hause fühlen
nämlich mehr oder weniger das platt und
alles soll knies machen
also wenn wir hören dass eine frau eine
philosophin war müssen wir vorsichtig
sein aber das vorausgesagt da kann man
auch sagen dass in vielen von diesen
philosophischen bewegungen frauen mit
beteiligt worden und frage wie kann das
sein also wenn fragen so an dem haushalt
gebunden sind wie kann es sein dass sie
auch in diesem film solchen kreisen
tätig waren
und das ist noch mal wie fast immer
unterschiedlich beantworten und bei
manchen bewegungen haben wir mit mit
einer philosophie zu tun die aus
sichtlich gegen kulturelle enormen
gestaltet
zum beispiel die zyniker die zyniker
waren dadurch definiert dass sie
gesellschaftliche erwartungen ab
geschaffen haben oder zurückgewiesen
haben
und anders gelebt haben wie normale
menschen
neben uns beispiel von mir die option
ist der begründer des zionismus geht es
zum theater und wenn das theaterstück
aus ist und das ganze vorgekommen bleibt
vom theater strömt ddr ein
das klingt nicht wie philosophie aber
der punkt dahinter ist ich mache genau
nicht das was ihr alle
8 also er ist susan der gegenstrom der
normalen kurzen bewegung erwartungen und
deswegen können wir sagen in diesen in
diesen fällen die frauen die an der
philosophie mitgeteilt worden
die haben die erwartungen der
gesellschaft zurück gewiesen und so
sagen wie männer gelebt oder sogar
mitglied meiner sondern wie zyniker also
obdachlos in der straße und das überlebt
bis in die spätantike so dass wir dann
christliche asketische frauen haben die
auch so leben
mehr darüber in späteren vorlesungen
aber dass es eine möglichkeit aber die
andere möglichkeit ist wir haben
weibliche philosophinnen die oder
mindestens schülerinnen die in einem
philosophie philosophischem kreis
anwesend sind
wahrscheinlich weil sie als frau eines
philosophen philosoph da sind zum
beispiel ein philosoph und ist das ist
jetzt hier mehr leckere mehr relevant
für die römische zeit wir haben eine
philosophische schule der haupt
philosoph hält vorträge oder führt
seminare und aristokraten dürfen
teilnehmen
anwesend sein und manchmal kommen auch
frau desto kritische fragen freundinnen
des philosophen bruder flights ehefrauen
der der anteil eines anderen
mitgeteilten usw
ein schönes beispiel die wir später
erwähnt werden ist die frau von piräus
ein neutron icke & er hat einen für
solchen brief an seine frau geschrieben
und es scheint irgendwie war es zu
setzen dass sie auch eine philosophin
ist oder philosophisch leben sogar
früher also jetzt in der griechischen
antike
diese philosophie fahren die oder
philosophische schulen oder kreise die
fragen zugelassen haben
ohne vorauszusetzen wir weisen die ganze
gesellschaftliche erwartungen zurück zum
beispiel platon akademie hat frauen als
schülerinnen gehabt angeblich werde ich
dann später mehr darüber sagen
und das bringt uns zu unserer ersten
wichtigen gruppe der philosophen nämlich
die pid al gore rennen weil wir hier mit
dem ersten film kreis zu tun wo frauen
anscheinend tätig sind und wenn wir
jetzt sagen das ist das ist der erste
fall
man könnte fast sagen natürlich ist es
der erste fall war das ist so viel dass
es was am anfang ist weil pythagoras ist
vanessa grass hat bezeichnete es
überhaupt gelebt nie zu sicher aber lang
vor flattern ließ auf jeden fall sechste
jahrhundert vor christus breit und die
idee ist dass in seinem kreis frauen
eine rolle gespielt haben
und das werde ich jetzt sprechen aber
zuerst mache ich pause damit jemanden
fragen stellen kann wenn er oder sie
bemerken
nein keine frage
ja stimmt ja ja ja das stimmt und musik
hält man sagen nie vergessen
das okay ab und zu darf dem man das
vergessen aber jetzt können wir daran
denken dass musik also musik muss
musicals serie führen die aber ein
musiker ist eine sehr breite ausbildung
und manchmal wird musik nicht als musik
ihre übersetzung als kultur oder
ausbildung im allgemeinen über satz aber
musik war dabei und muss sich jetzt
natürlich angemerkt mathematische kunst
also mathematisch ist hier richtig und
wir werden das später auch partner sehen
dass wir sogar antike frauen die es in
mathematik spezialisiert waren also
mathematik und frauen ist man könnte
wahrscheinlich eine vorlesung serie über
frauen und wissenschaft halten also
frauen als als beobachtung der
wissenschaft aber auch frauen aus
wissenschaftlerinnen in der artikel wie
viel das wirklich gibt dazu sagen bin
ich ein bisschen skeptisch aber
mathematik müsste eine rolle spielen
denn nur wegen der partie aber im
allgemeinen können wird sie haben recht
davon ausging genau wie diese frauen
lesen und schreiben können müssten dann
auch rechnen
allerdings gehe ich davon
ich dachte sie würden was anderes sagen
nämlich dann gehen sie bestimmt
einkaufen oder synthetik ende aber dafür
gibt es klagen
übrigens ist also wie die also diese
dort diese beobachtung die frage die
frauen mussten nichts einkaufen gehen
weil sie sklaven hatten aber die sklaven
die geschickt wurden wurde waren mal
aufladen
also ich meine was ich damit meine ist
aristokratische frauen sind und deswegen
übrigens diese bekannt dieses bekannte
phänomen das bei schönheit einer frau
besteht zum teil aus glas sein also
weiße haut weil man so wenig an der
sonne ist
und das heißt dass man gleich ist aber
nicht immer zu hause ist das ein
bisschen ein klischee aber
wahrscheinlich mindestens teilweise zu
gute frage
wahrscheinlich von als kinder schon und
mindestens in der römisch römischen zeit
von sklaven vorwiegend es gibt sogar in
einem brief den ich dann bald gespräche
steht es an
man soll man soll für die kinder
die kennt das werden müssen von sklaven
betreut werden
möglichst von einem griechen nicht von
einem nicht von barbarischem sklaven
wahrscheinlich weil die bahn kein
grieche sprechen können oder nicht gut
spielt können können allerdings erfahren
wir auch das fahren diese haushalt kunst
die wirklich so dominant ist für die
frauen
das würde entweder von der mutter schon
übernommen oder übertragen könnte man
sagen oder auch von den ehemann
also manchmal steht dass in diesen
texten und das ein guter ehemann die
aufgabe hat der frau zu erziehen dass
sie das haushalt gut führt zum beispiel
zum beispiel so etwas wie rechnen war
unterrichten werde meines wissens nicht
geschlossen kann hier ist wird auch
wieder relevanz zu noch mal so sagen
dass sie schon mit vielleicht mit 15
oder sowas heiraten wollen sie waren aus
unserer sicht noch kennt ja also es war
noch viel zu lernen
sozusagen gut weil das ist überhaupt
nicht mein gebiet jetzt gehen wir so für
das vieh und zu dieser angeblichen
kritikerinnen ich habe schon letzte
woche gesagt dass wir im allgemeinen das
problem haben uns zu entscheiden oder zu
wissen ob aldi philosophinnen die wir
gerne sprechen würden und lesen würden
wirklich echt waren also ob sie
überhaupt existiert haben
und das ist hier der fall also das ist
schon hier ein problem
und wie gesagt wir haben hier mit
figuren aus der pädagogischen tradition
zu tun
das heißt aus einer philosophischen aber
auch religiösen traditionen die diese
rabatte oder uhr figur pythagoras hat
und pythagoras selbst normal also
normalerweise wird er als vorzug artikel
betrachtet also in sammlungen über
physikalische flow sowie gibt es
eigentlich immer ein kapitel über
pythagoras und die partita gorilla
gorilla
allerdings wäre es wahrscheinlich
fraglich die terrorismus als profis zu
betiteln wenn man sozusagen nur tages
hatte er es eher ein mystische figur die
als vorbild und held von uns späteren
philosophen genommen würde
und das bis in die spätantike
viele quellen die in beschwerden sind
auch aus der spätantike zb aus dem
vierten jahrhundert nach christus also
eine hauptquelle zum beispiel ist das
leben des pythagoras von ihr anblick der
im vierten jahrhundert nach christus
lebte
das heißt mehr oder weniger tausend
jahre in acht pythagoras oder fast so
wie sie können sich vorstellen wie
realistisch es ist zu erwarten dass wir
hier echte informationen über den echten
pythagoras haben
aber wer angeblich war er das wissen sie
wahrscheinlich schon dass er sehr mit
mathematik verbunden ist dass er
angeblich mehrere mit mathematische es
gibt bekanntlich dieses italienische
gesetz über drei akten die ich jetzt
nicht erklären werde in der hoffnung
dass sie das alte wissen und verweilt
das budget passen würde
das wäre peinlich und und dann danach
gibt es eine reihe von anderen figuren
die ideen von ihm übernehmen und wie
gesagt das wissen die spätantike also
tief in die römische zeit allerdings wie
gesagt das ist auch eine religiöse
bewegung und die tourismus war meiner
meinung nach für den durchschnittlichen
antiken mensch hat mindestens so viel zu
tun damit dass diese spezialgeräte
einige flaschen geschlossene
gesellschaft waren mit ganz bestimmte
regeln wie sie sich vorgenommen haben
wie sie der wie vizepräsident ritual
gegen überhaupt gestellt worden und so
weiter zb sie dürfen nichts über die
katholische lehre erzählen also die die
meisten schweigen
die mussten eine bestimmte teams haben
die wahl italien
vielleicht weil sie an wiedergeburt
geklappt haben mindestens bei empedokles
ein späterer peugeot kritiker der sehr
von peta us- band los wurde haben wir
eine stelle eine passage ein bruchstück
wo er sich vorstellt dass ein mann
seinen eigenen großvater glaube ich ist
das ist weil der großvater als tier
wiedergeboren ist und dann wird das tier
dann geopfert und das enkelkind ist
seinen eigenen großvater wuchs
kann passieren also ein guter grund
vegetarisch sein
und die dürfen auch keine bohnen essen
usw sind sie müssen sich in eine besser
besondere art und weise hans sein als
eine philosophische schule was natürlich
sind die zwei sachen eng verbunden hier
und jetzt können wir denken okay dass
wenn es wenn es einen plausiblen
zusammenhang geben könnte für
philosophinnen dann hier war hier haben
wir geschlossene kreis geheimnisvolle
gruppe von nicht nur männer sondern
familien die die gleiche religiös
religiöse oder die die religiöse regeln
befolgt haben und da sich dadurch
definiert haben und deswegen gibt es
nicht nur für tage rheinische frauen
männer sondern auch frauen tatsächlich
gibt es sogar ein beleg dafür dass
pythagoras seine lehre von einer frau
übernommen hat nämlich zehn ist okay
wenn das stimmen würde könnten wir sagen
dass all die hauptströmungen der antiken
philosophie alles von einer frau ab
stand nämlich diese tipps zu klären und
dieser im blick oder ihm wir werden
normalerweise hier ein blick auf deutsch
genannt der dieses leben des pythagoras
geschrieben hat der überliefert eine
liste von 17 kategorien also alle frauen
und zwei die da auftauchen sind terrano
und neuer
theater ist die frau des pythagoras
vielleicht das da ist sind die belege in
der antiken literatur umstritten oder es
wird hat anders berichtet manchmal ist
sie seine schulden manchmal ist sie
seine tochter manchmal ist sie seine
frau
wir müssen hoffen dass sie nicht alle
drei war aber vielleicht war die schüler
und frau zum beispiel mehr wäre dann die
tochter des betrachters angeblich also
man könnte sich vorstellen ok super wir
haben diese gruppe von also ein kreis
von schüler- und vielleicht sogar eine
lehrerin die im umfeld von pythagoras
tätig waren und die haben alle
pädagogische philosophie und religion
ausgeführt beton ist schon schrecklich
am anfang der philosophie bisher hat
fast nichts passiert
also wir haben die digitale ist ein
maximaler exters heraklion offen ist und
dann pythagoras also wenn praktisch
innerhalb den ersten zehn für das offen
überhaupt und schon tauchen die frauen
auf wir bringen
aber da müssen wir vorsichtig sein was
haben wir als literatur die uns was über
diese frauen ok erstens haben wir viele
legenden und anekdoten
über peters sowieso und dann mehrere
mitglieder seines kreises einschließlich
diese fan und am häufigsten treten auf
es gibt mehrere geschichten und
anekdoten über sie die beste meiner
meinung nach sie ist bei den besten
spiele und zeigt ausgesehen wie bisher
und jemand gemerkt wie schön ihr arm ist
und dann sagt sie das ist nicht für die
öffentlichkeit nichts für die
öffentlichkeit also ist nichts war nicht
so dass ein
das ist vielleicht nur für meine familie
zu sehen könnte das heißen das könnte
das natürlich ist das auslegen aber die
idee scheint viel ddr scheint zu sein
dass sie so dass sie so nicht schütteln
ist aber sie benimmt sich so gut dass
sie nicht einmal ihre anzeigen will in
der öffentlichkeit das passt natürlich
zu dem was ich schon über frauen gesagt
habe das beispiel ciano wird gefragt
nach dem 1 1 eine frau sexualverkehr
genossen hat wie lange sie warten bis
sie an der religiösen ritual beteiligt
ist
antwort wenn das mit ihrem mann war dann
musste ich überhaupt nicht warten
aber wenn es wenn es nicht mit ihrem
mann war dann ist sie für vier hände
reiben
ok also dass das ist nicht sehr
philosophisch aber passt ja gut so eine
thematik die sehr oft in diesem text
nervt haut nämlich sechs mit dem man gut
6 mit anderen sehr schlecht das ist
wirklich ein thema das durch diese
pädagogische text ist also das ist ein
dauerläufer so ist sagen dann kommt
mehrmals vor also außer diesen legenden
haben wir dann was interessant ist
könnte man meinen nämlich mehrere briefe
die von angeblich von peta gerinnen
verfasst wurden
und wenn sie in diesem buch das das
steht auf der liste die ich schon in der
ersten woche verteilt habe übrigens
kurze bemerkung oder durchsage an haben
sie alle schon nachgeschaut ob sie
zugang an diese texte haben konnten von
meinem website hoffentlich funktioniert
also die sind als pdfs klar zugreifbar
haben eine website unter lärm also unter
sich und dann hier an der lmu website
und dann unter der lehrveranstaltungen
und jede woche werde ich neue texte
aufladen falls sie das sehen wollen und
sie werden vielleicht schon gemerkt
haben wenn sie das gemacht haben dass
die lesungen
ich glaube bisher ausschließlich auf
englisch waren
das ist das hat mehrere erklärungen
dahinter erstens wäre nicht versucht
habe klein zu finden vorwiegend was ich
gefunden habe war auf englisch aber auch
weil ich zum beispiel plattform auf
deutsch zugänglich zu machen scheint mir
nicht sinnvoll also gehe davon aus wenn
sie einen teil der politik platons lesen
wollen werden sie schon in der
sein das zu tun also ich habe eher
schwierige schwierige greifbare sachen
genommen und diesen vorwiegend auf
englisch das natürlich auch was ich
vorzüglich gelesen habe muss ich zugeben
aber ich denke haben es wirklich der
fall dass die literatur so fragen in der
antiken philosophie vorwiegend auf
englisch sowie soll ist habe falls
jemand vorschläge hat was sich auf
deutsch aufladen sollte oder hätten
sollte dann können sie mir gerne sagen
okay so zurück zum thema die eine quelle
die dort zugänglich gemacht habe ist ein
kapitel aus diesem buch von waits die
schon auf der liste der bürger für die
ich letzte woche verteilt habe und das
heißt ich glaube dass history of lovers
band 1 managen und was sie dort macht
ist es sehr nützlich
sie sammelt die quellen und übersetzt
sie in englisch also sehr gut wenn man
diese dieser text ist das wenn man alt
wie ich kann
die sind nicht leicht unter anderem sind
sie nicht einmal in taktischen
griechisch sondern auf tore aus gründen
die ich bald erklären werde
aber die sind einfach schwierige texte
und an ist gut dass sie zum auf englisch
zugänglich sind
aber was nicht so beschädigen ist dass
sie sind sie wohl wirklich belegen
möglichst wenn sie kann möchte sie
belegen dass diese dass diese frauen
wirklich existiert haben also dass diese
texte wirklich echt sind und vielleicht
deswegen nimmt die sozusagen pauschale
aldi peter gallerinnen zusammen und
behandelt sie sozusagen
chronologisch dass du zuerst die
pädagoginnen die in der zeit des
pythagoras tätig waren und dann die
späte debüt tage reden aber es ist fast
sicher der fall dass alle diese texte
viel später geschieden worden
also auch später als die angebliche
zweite generation der digital ernennen
und zwar zwischen den zweiten
jahrhundert vor christus
jahrhundert nach christus also in der
hellenistischen würde sogar kaiserlichen
römischen seitz und das heißt wir haben
hier damit zu tun dass wir zb grafische
texte haben also texte die an anderen
berühmten personen zugeschrieben werden
damit die texte besser bei einem
publikum ankommen und das passt zudem
ziemlich gut was sie gerade gesagt habe
nämlich dass zum beispiel piano schon
bekannt war als berühmte person die
bekannt war als pythagoras ist ehefrau
die mit dem schönen und deswegen wenn
man einen brief schreiben will wo man
beschreibt wie eine pädagogische frau
sich benehmen soll schreibt man gerne
als ob man theater wäre okay also sieht
nimmt sie alle zusammen zusammen ohne zu
bemerken dass wir eigentlich hier zwei
gruppen von briefen haben und die
überlieferung der briefe ist sehr anders
eine gruppe hat eine überliefert eine
eine unabhängige überlieferung in
verschiedenen handschriften und tauchen
zusammen auf als fünf briefe von
insgesamt drei philosophen und die
angebliche verfasserinnen sind partie
hannover melissa und mehr
sie wissen schon wer tja nun wir sind
die sind die frau wahrscheinlich frau
und tochter des pythagoras wer es
minister wir sind gehen nicht aber ein
ein vorschlag was riezinger macht
übrigens unten auf dem hand sehen sie
das werde ich immer machen eine kurze
biografie zum thema der heutigen
vorlesungen geben und dieses buch von
hietzing er ist wirklich sehr nützlich
weil sie diese gruppe von fünf briefe
wirklich sehr detailliert beschreibt und
auch ediert und übersetzt und die
übersetzungen sind auch besser als die
in meiner meinung nach auf jeden fall
sie
sie schlägt vor dass dieser name melissa
ausgewählt würde um ihre touren dann
irgendwie auszudrücken weil minister
heißt auf altgriechisch biene und bienen
sind natürlich bekannt dafür dass sie
sehr ordentlich leben und dass sie eine
sehr dass das sie ja eine sehr
ordentliche gesellschaft führen und dass
es genau das wofür man steht in dem
brief dass er vorschlagen
also das ist reine spekulation aber ich
kann schön als eine reine spekulation
auf jeden fall da haben wir diese diese
drei autoren nennen waren die diese fünf
briefe geschrieben haben es gibt einen
brief von mindesten jeweils zwei von ca
die themen sind eigentlich die themen
die wir fast erwarten würden nämlich
haushalts thema also wie man als frau
vorgehen soll zum beispiel ein brief ist
wird eine einer anderen frau
geschrieben und es am anfang sagt die
die verfasserin ich habe verstanden dass
ihr ehemann fremdgegangen ist was
natürlich schlecht ist aber die frage
ist wie sie jetzt damit unwahrscheinlich
wie du jetzt und damit umgehen wirst und
ich möchte dir sagen dass du auf keinen
fall selber film gangster sondern hast
du dein mann zurückgewinnen
dadurch trägt es dazu ist sehr nett zu
ihnen bist das ist die beratung und du
sollst keine rache gegen die liebhaberin
ausüben sondern sie einfach ignorieren
und du sollst dich auch nicht steigen
lassen weil wir dich scheiden und wer
dann wirst du nie wieder heiraten und
dein nächster hellmann wird auch für
angehen
also irgendwie aus versehen lustig muss
man sagen und die beratung ist nicht
gerade die wir jetzt einer frau geben
würde in dieser situation das ist ein
beispiel an der hauptthemen sind zum
beispiel erziehung der kinder ein brief
ist diesem thema gewidmet
und da liest man zum beispiel diese
beratung über die zum beispiel fand das
stück vor dass man auf jeden fall selber
das camp stellen soll
aber wenn das nicht hinhaut dass man
eine partnerschaft deutsch dass man eine
armee finden soll und dann bescheid wie
die arme sein sollten oder eben dass man
das kind nicht zu einem barbarischen
sklaven geben soll so einem griechischen
wenn's geht dass man kinder nicht zu
viel essen geben soll sondern müssen sie
hart bleiben und mit wenig auskommen
können
die sollen nicht zuviel geschütz gegen
wärme und kälte und so weiter und so
fort das ist so
das ist die beratung und so weiter
wahrscheinlich fast schon erwähnt habe
ist die beziehung mit dem ehemann
vielleicht das hauptthema
also was wirklich was wirklich zählt ist
dass die hausherren
zusammen mit dem haus erarbeitet um das
haus gut zu funktionieren zu lassen
interessant sich hier übrigens zu
bemerken dass diese briefe nicht nur von
frauen geschrieben wort würden sondern
wie sich und gesehen haben für frauen
und laut hiesinger das kann ich nicht
selber belegen oder beweisen aber laut
ihr sind diese fünf briefe die einzige
briefe aus der antike die eine weibliche
star
autoren haben uns ein weiblicher
empfängerin also frau frau brief gibt es
keine bisher auf diese fünf weiß nicht
ob sie griechisch mainz oder auch latein
aber falls jemand eine ausnahme kämpfen
jemand eine ausnahme antike brief von
einer klar für eine andere frau
okay soweit wir wissen hat sie recht
also selbst das ist interessant
natürlich gibt es auch keine
philosophische briefe die von frauen für
frauen geschrieben wurden das ist eine
gruppe von briefe die andere grippe
die andere gruppe ist ausschließlich bei
einem spätantiken christliche natur zu
finden namens tobias es gibt das ein
interessantes thema für sich
es gibt eine entwicklung in der
byzantinischen tradition wo
schriftsteller die schriften und texte
von früheren autoren gesammelt haben ihm
ganz ganz also riesige büchern was für
uns wirklich wertvoll ist weil diese
texte oft sonst verloren lernen profil
angegangen werden einschließlich diese
texte die wir bei studios wenden und
diese texte besprechen öfter themen die
wir wirklich mit kategorischen
philosophie verbinden würde
die autorinnen hier sind später als die
fünf briefe die die von denen fünf
liefen die ich schon beschrieben habe
nämlich erfinders bund peretti ohne wer
ist perfektion weiß das jemand
für 20 cent wer weiß wer per juni war
die mutter platons co
also wir haben zwei bruchstücke aus
werke von der mutter platons redaktion
und das kann doch kein zufall sein
die ideen in diesen grundstücke erinnern
sehr an platons ideen also platon hat es
alles von der liebe mutter gelernt
anscheinend oder eben die diese die
texte sind nach platonische texte und
übernehmen ideenhaus platt ans werk was
denke ich viel wahrscheinlicher ist es
gibt zwei werke von hier ein werk über
die weisheit ein anderes werk über so
vorsieht also die haupt jugend für
frauen sowie volks office of roses
moderation und das sehen wir sehr oft in
diesen werken dass die dass die tugenden
für frauen anders sind als die tum für
männer
weil männer an in der police also in der
stadt tätig sein müssen die müssen
tapfer im krieg kämpfen usw
denn die hauptbedingung für eine frau
gründlichste sein ist dass sie software
ist also dass sie model hat ist unter
anderem sie 06 mit dem band begehen ja
dass das gehört dazu und diese andere
haben diese andere beratung die in den
texten film hat hauptsächlich damit zu
tun also nicht mit sex sondern mit sony
zu verkörpern es wirklich die idee
allerdings man kann auch sagen dass wir
das habe ich schon gesagt dass das erz
philosophische themen er hier vorkommen
als in den fünf spiele so wie es ist
das würde ich nicht sagen offensichtlich
wird philosophisch besser also die diese
bruchstücke sind offensichtlicher
philosophisch zum beispiel sagt
partizipation der härte weise ist der
der alle dinge zu einem prinzip
zurückführen kann hat nichts mit
aussagen zu tun nichts mit frauen mit
kindern ist wirklich bis zum logo oder
mathe physik nicht sehr viel aber dass
mindestens irgendwas was man auch oft
sehr oft hier vorsieht ist dass die dass
die frauen die die weibliche autorinnen
die den zustand der tugendhaften ziele
beschreiben nach musste der tugend lehre
des plateaus nämlich
[Musik]
abwasser bestimmte alles in einer
kleinen tasche welche farbe ja klar
also wir haben die menschliche seele
das hat thomas sind wir schwer für mich
zu übersetzen das ist der teil der serie
womit wir erst wenn wir uns ärgern und
was nach erde strebt also schwer zu
übersetzen
auf englisch wird immer aus pieritz
übersetzt auf jeden fall ist die idee
damit decken wir und damit gehen wir die
wahrheit nach damit gehen wir die erde
nach und damit verlangen wir nach lust
körperliche lust und vielleicht auch
geld hier warum geld her wahrscheinlich
weil mit geld kann man essen und andere
lust besorgt es kommt zusammen und diese
theorie wir relativ ausführlich in
diesen texten erklärt und platonisch als
den zustand beschrieben den zustand
beschrieben wo die begierde die 5 volt
also es natürlich nichts level 0 serie
produziert
aber es zeigt dass diese texte ideen aus
der philosophischen geschichte oder
ausbildungshilfen anderen für solchen
texten übernehmen und wenn wir das
überlegen uns zurück zu der anderen
texte schauen die texte für die fünf
briefe können wir vielleicht sogar
erkennen dass diese briefe philosophisch
sind als wir zuerst daten weil ab und
zoom in diesen texten die idee vorkommt
dass man das haushalt führen muss mit
gerechtigkeit und mit so flossen also
das heißt der der das haus muss eine
ordnung haben genau wie die richtige
seele und zum beispiel ein brief fängt
damit an dass man das gerechtigkeit in
der in dem haus herrschen muss genau wie
in der stadt
und ich würde sogar sagen dass diese
briefe also die fünf briefe die
unabhängig über liefert sind und die
texte bei stop es so sagen das und das
können sie lesen ist alles zugänglich
auf der website dass sie können sich
entscheiden ob ich recht habe
aber ich würde sagen dass sie ein gutes
beispiel dafür sind dass wir wie oft in
der antiken philosophie ein parallel
sehen zwischen haushalt
polis der stadt und in jedem fall in
jedem fall für das sage es nicht dass
wir einen text haben haben in diesen
texten die alle viel miteinander
vergleicht sondern haben wir passagen
die haushalt mit polis vergleichen oder
hals hat mit cast kosmos oder seele
mietshaus oder wie auch immer also die
idee ist dass in jedem fall die richtige
ordnung herrschen muss damit man
erfolgreich aus kommt zum beispiel wenn
man die tugend haben will muss vernunft
an der an der macht seien und diese
teile die sie unsere cent teilen müssen
der vernunft ball ähnlicher weise
bekannterweise aus der politik platins
politik haben wir drei schichten die
philosophen könige und königinnen die
wir sehen wenn die soldaten und die
handwerker also könige soldaten
handwerker im haushalt haben wir ganz
oben dem hausherr den hausherr dann die
hausfrau die mit ihm das haus gestaltet
sklaven und kinder wurde er kennt es
bleiben und wenn alles zusammen arbeitet
wie es soll dann wird das haushalt reich
und im kosmos natürlich gibt es auch
eine ordnung die von von den göttern
oder nur von einem gott gestaltet wird
wollte merz in jedem fall gibt es ein
führender prinzip und ihm müssen alle
andere folgen also vernunft klinik oder
gott und das ist kein zufall also die
idee ist sagen diese hierarchische
strukturen die in allen vier
zusammenhängen paten und diese
theologische texte schildern diese
relativ weit verbreitete artikel die die
wir bei platten sehen aber bei vielen
anderen autoren auch in diesen texten
ist die hauptquelle dafür plattform
allerdings kann man das weltweit als
pädagogische theorie verkaufen weil das
hat alles mit harmonie und ordnungen zu
tun also man könnte sagen dass es sei
mathematisch oder arithmetisch man
könnte sogar wenn man ihn wirklich
wirklich integrierte stimmung wäre
könnte man sogar sagen dass die zahlen
hat die gleichen prinzip gebaut sind 1
und dann die anbieter zahlen werden
daraus produziert genau wie das
universum aus dem einen gott ihren platz
muss das eigentlich nichts bei diesen
texten auf aber kommt es kommt später
sehr stark durch in neue pädagogische
texte und nazismus und diese passage die
ich schon erwähnt habe
wo projektionen sagt dass der weise
derjenige ist der alles zurück zu einem
prinzip führen kann
das entspricht mehr oder weniger diese
aufpassen
also dass das ist sozusagen ein versuch
die die versteckte philosophische themen
zu finden die in diesen texten zu finden
sind
natürlich gibt es noch die hauptfrage
wer hat das alles geschieht
die hat schon gesagt dass es sehr sehr
unwahrscheinlich bis unmöglich ist dass
die fünf dass die sammlung von fünf
briefe von den angeblichen autorinnen
verfasst wurden
das scheint vielmehr eine hellenistische
ein versuch von realistischen autoren
oder autorinnen
eine ethik für house fahren zu
beschreiben so beschreibt das ritzing
also sie
sie beschreibt es so was wie ich wollte
das mitbringen der zitat ist sowas wie
vor house of management oder frau sie
sagt nicht fahren ich glaube dass das
oft wickel zu allerdings gibt es wie
gesagt diese leise momente wo
italienische ideen doch durch kommen
vielleicht stärker bei den anderen texte
die wir bei studenten aber natürlich
beantwortet das nicht die frage wer das
geschrieben hat also alles was wir sagen
können ist aus verschiedenen gründen und
und übrigens die gründen an vorwiegend
mit sprachanalyse zu tun sondern die
briefe nicht so viel
die sind zwar auf deutsch
also diese der also eine art
altgriechisch die die beta gora benutzt
haben
aber das ist deswegen weil die leute in
der englischen seite gewusst haben dass
die leute damals auf deutsch geschrieben
haben und deswegen um das als
beteiligung zu verkaufen haben sie das
so geschrieben das wäre als ob sie einen
brief schreiben wollen und sie wollen
sagen das ist von goethe sie sagen
nichts zu sagen jetzigen deutsch sondern
in einem sehr gut deutsch und in
dreizehn jahrhunderte deutsch sozusagen
habe noch klasse meint die unterschiede
sind noch klasse ok also nichts von
tirano wer und ministers werke massiver
also von wem
antwort wir wissen nichts es ist ja
schön wenn du wissen würden
ich glaube die die gäste antwort wird
von hietzinger gegeben nämlich dass für
einfach einfach zu wenig informationen
haben wales will natürlich mindestens
dass die verfasserin wenn es nicht
wirklich so weit sind sie will
mindestens dass die verfasser frauen
sind und einen vorschlag was sie nicht
von ihr sondern was sie zitiert ist das
spätere frauen in der kita garagen
bewegung die die dabei waren haben sich
vielleicht nach diese nur figuren also
piano eine andere therapie als der
kriterien war es sie nach der
durchschnittlichen ciano genannt würde
das klappt aber ich denke sehr
unwahrscheinlich denn wir haben andere
texte viele andere texte die peter allen
kategorien zugeschrieben werden aber die
pythagoras sind männer
und sind es zb quark oder selbst und
seine unmittelbare nachfolger also das
heißt aber wir haben wirklich eine weit
verbreitete ein weiteres kommt wo wir
sollte begriff zmp grafische texte in
der patagonischen tradition finden die
tatsache dass diese briefe frauen
zugeschrieben werden hat mit dem thema
zu tun also bei sie das thema haushalt
besprechen wollten haben sie berühmte
weibliche namen genommen wenn sie petra
englische einstigen zum krieg
beschreiben wollten hätten sie das
tages- oder einen ähnlichen anderen
männlichen autor zugeschrieben natürlich
schließt das aber nicht aus dass die
verfasser auch frauen war mein sie
schreiben für frauen und geben beratung
darüber wie man als frau leben soll
man könnte vielleicht sogar sagen dass
es weniger der primären hinsichtlich zum
beispiel diese beratung wenn dein mann
fremdgeht sei einfach nett zu ihm
also da denkt man vielleicht erstens
wahrscheinlich von einem mann
geschrieben vielleicht noch ein mann der
gern fremdgeht
und zweitens es wäre besser wenn es von
einem mann geschrieben wäre als zu
denken eine frau hat das geschieht aber
wir wissen das einfach nicht
leider allerdings finde ich persönlich
finde es überhaupt nicht unplausibel zu
vermuten dass wir hier wirklich eine
lehre von frauen an anderen frauen haben
und mit also wenn man mehr als
möglichkeit ampel muss man das care-team
unzufrieden bleiben
in den letzten viertelstunde wollte ich
dann einen noch ein beispiel besprechen
dass wir eigentlich bei platin finden
oder hat jemand fragen über diese
tragische texte gute frage
das würde versucht und ich habe ja wie
das gelesen ich habe etwas darüber
gelesen also und es gibt leute die
behaupten dass das möglich sei
aber es würde nie beschrieben also oder
nie bewiesen dass es möglich ist dass
man natürlich machen müsste ist texten
zu nehmen die sicherlich von frauen
geschickt werden sicherlich von männern
und dann blind also sozusagen hat tarnen
also abdecken
es ist man oder frau und dann tasten ob
wir das erkennen können
aber wir haben überhaupt keine texte die
aus der antike kommen die sicherlich von
frauen geschrieben würden wir wissen
sind diese branche der literatur
also die also das einzige was diese
texte als markiert als von frauen ist
das also die über chef sagt das ist der
brief von piano an wen auch immer also
das wären dann sind die themen passen
für eine weibliche wollte aber
eigentlich dachte umgekehrt ob sie fragt
ob sie sagen wollten dass wir vielleicht
besten könnten ob das wirklich von einer
frau ist dadurch dass wir irgendwie
erkennen dass frauen öfter hernehmen
oder was ein
aber wie gesagt ich habe eine bestattung
dieser idee gelesen aber es war sehr
skeptisch
und ich glaube sie recht vor allem muss
man müsste man nicht ausschließen selbst
wenn frauen irgendwie weiblich schreiben
kann ein mann das nachahmen
ein guter chef star langguth ja also ich
bin sehr skeptisch
die frage steht also zb shakespeare es
wird alles von seiner mutter geschenkt
ok gute frage es gibt viele
es gibt viele texte es gibt die texte
die wir lesen die fast immer sehr
berühmte texte von sehr berühmten
autoren sind platon aristoteles wenn man
betrachtet wie wie viele philosophische
texte wirklich vorhandener verhalten
sind als der antike haben wir mit vielen
vielen texten zu tun die anonym cent ok
alle gehen natürlich davon hast dass sie
von männern geschrieben würden von
nichts von frauen ohne beweis dafür
dann haben wir viele texte die berühmten
zugeschrieben werden die aus irgendeinem
grund geht zweifelhaft sind zum beispiel
viele platonische dialoge die
wahrscheinlich von platon beschrieben
wurden
also was die statistik ist für texte wo
wir wissen sicher werde auto ist und wer
nicht
und wo nicht ich weiß es nicht aber es
gibt genügend texte wo der autor
fraglich ist oder unbekannt haben die
frage ist einfach ob es plausibel ist
aus irgendeinem grund anzunehmen dass
marke von diesem text und
frauengeschichten
und hinsichtlich die schwierige lage
verfahren
ich glaube es nicht nicht unberechtigt
davon auszugehen dass das ist wenige
texte von frauen gegeben hat und dass
die texte die fragen geschickt die vor
allem wirklich verfasst haben nicht
erhalten sind aber der zweite kann man
das nicht ausschließen dass irgendein
anonymer text von einer frau geschrieben
war
kann sein so würde ich nicht als basis
sie ist eine figur die uns jetzt zum
platon führt ich habe auch überlegt ob
ich sie eher nächste woche besprechen
sollte wo ich frau und bei platten und
hat es dort ließ thematisieren werde
aber ich dachte das passt jetzt besser
hoffentlich werden sie sehen weil
erstens war was sie anscheinend eine
echte person die vor platon geht hat sie
war in dem in dem jahrhundert vor
steuern zusammen und war bekannte und
vielleicht liebhaber denn von panels der
grund für des a teams werden den
peloponnesischen krieg und sie war sehr
bekannt als nicht nur kumpel von kelis
und wie gesagt vielleicht lieber drin
sondern auch als kumpel von lockert es
sieht auch bei mehreren autoren auf die
schüler von sarkozys waren platon aber
nicht nur platten sondern andere so
kritiker zbs knies und ein tischtennis
sie haben beide sogar gesundheit
sie haben beide sogar dialoge
geschrieben die nach ihr genannt wurden
also dass aspasia
das buch heißt es war sie leider das
sind die beiden natürlich verloren
allerdings haben wir zitate aus oder
mindestens beschreibungen des inhalts in
späteren eltern vorhanden und sie
scheint so zu sagen
sie kommt irgendwie fast wie ein
weiblicher stalker thies vor als sie für
zum beispiel philosophische dialoge oder
kurze wieder lenkungen durch und taucht
in dieser weise bei xenophon auf sie
wissen wahrscheinlich dass davon ein
also dass der produkte historiker ja er
war auch schüler von sokratis genau wie
plattform und hat dann werke geschrieben
hat werke über geschichte geschrieben
über seine erfahrungen im krieg aber
auch über soccer teams von der text ist
die memorabilia und in diesem text das
war sie ein paar mal auf zum beispiel in
diesen sokratischen werken tauscht sie
auf was sie glaubt sie
sie spricht mit seiner frau und seiner
frau und dann schlagt sie sänger von an
ob er gern einen kurzen ein gutes pferd
hätte oder ein schlechtes wert ein gutes
werk ein schönes haus oder ein
schlechtes aus ein schönes haus dann
eine schöne eine gute frau oder eine
schlechte frau und seine seine klasse
dar
und weil natürlich ist es impliziert
wenn sie nicht eine gute frau ist sonst
so sie soll er sie wegschicken
und dann sagt sie genau dasselbe zu der
frau und dann sei schluss ist dass es
war sehr sagt ob das das zeigt dass ihr
beide tugendhaft sein müssen denn der eu
praktisch weitergehen soll
weil sonst hättet ihr beide gründe
einander zu verlassen als ein bisschen
die wohl bemerkt dass ein bisschen wieso
hat es aber wieder hat mit diesem
haushalts thema zu tun also gut und so
weiter und die die kernidee dahinter wie
fast immer ist dass die situation der
frau ein haus nur dann gut wird und das
haus nur gut dann wird wenn ehemann und
vor allem ehefrau tugendhaft leben
okay aber die wichtigste stelle
patience auftaucht ist im dialog
managers wer hat das max season schon
von ihnen nicht sehr überraschend
also das gehört nicht zu den für den
beliebtesten sehen dialogen des platins
wohlmöglich nicht zu den beliebtesten 20
oder 25 ist was letztere rein aber gute
nachricht es ist sehr kurz dass sie
finden dass sie gibt es in einer halben
stunde locker lesen und besteht fast
ausschließlich von einer rede die von
aspasia gehalten wird nicht von melexis
ein externes ist also der dialog sollte
eigentlich als basel heißen und mit
nächsten das ist nur ein
ein anderer mann der sich mit soccer
teams unterhalten und verlangt von
sokratis das lockert es eine rede aus
seinem gedächtnis
es spricht dass er von espace ihr
gelernt hat wieso hat er das von etwa
sie gelernt weil wie vorher erwähnt als
basis seine rhetorik lehrer war
ich kann der kann das ziemlich auswendig
weil sie mit geprügelt hat jedes mal
dass ich was was gemerkt habe und
deswegen da entfaltet er dann die rede
und am ende ist sagt mir nächstes das
ist so was wie das ist wirklich
beeindrucken wenn sie das sogar als frau
machen könnte es ist so eine rede
verfassen als frau und ich denke dass es
nicht unrichtig weil es ein hinweis
darauf gibt dass platon wirklich es ist
wirklich so sagen platt und bewusst dass
es hier um eine frau geht also er
betrachtet das passiert nicht nur als
die berühmte leider denn von rettig
sondern als eine frau okay die rede ist
dann ein
das ist ein soldaten gewidmet die im
krieg gefallen sind athenischen soldaten
und angeblich würde die rede jedes jahr
nach platons tod würde dass jedes jahr
bis in bis zur sitzungszeit würde jedes
jahr vorgelesen in erde für die
kriegsgefangenen
das zeigt dass die antike laser und das
antike publikum den dialog wirklich
ernst genommen hat und schön gefunden
haben
allerdings wobei das mexikos
normalerweise wird als unrechts genommen
wird vom jetzigen forscher nehmen
viele nehmen hin als unseriös also die
denken dass eine parodie an sofas tische
redekunst weil es sehr nationalistisch
ist und der hauptthema ist athen ist
super super toll
während platon sonst überall hin
kritisiert ziemlich heftig
also ihr habt keine besondere stellung
dieser frage gebe und was überhaupt im
minus zuvor hatte das einzige was ich
bemerken gern bemerken würde ist in
diesem dialog ist dass diese dialog
nochmal uns darauf aufmerksam macht dass
frauen als sprecherinnen oft genommen
werden wenn ein männlicher autor themen
betonen will die mit frauen zu tun haben
man könnte vielleicht erwarten das ist
jetzt eine ein gegenbeispiel weil es
geht um geht und kriegsgefangenen
aber wenn man dann detailliert die rede
liest sieht man das als basis hauptpunkt
ist eben dass athen so erfolgreich war
weil athen immer wie eine familie war
sie sagt ganz am anfang dass die das
erde oder das land unter athen attika es
wie die mutter der bevölkerung und dass
diese gefallene söhne die söhne einem
einen einer guten mutter war sogar eine
mutter die sie gefüttert hat wie eine
stillende mutter sagt sie und dann
später beschreibt sie all die athena
also die männliche täter als söhne des
landes dann kommt eine rede innerhalb
der rede wo sie sagt was die väter der
söhne sagen zu der zu den zonen wenn sie
in krieg weg gehen und diese väter
betonen die beziehung zwischen vater und
sohn
aber wenn als basel wieder anfängt zu
denken sie produziert das nicht aber sie
wechsels des das hauptthema
man sagt dass der staat eigentlich der
vater für die soldaten ist oder der
vater der der ganzen bevölkerung des
landes die mutter der staat ist der
vater also meiner meinung nach
soweit ich weiß hat sonst keiner das
behauptet jetzt aber ich behaupte ich
behaupte mit betonung dass platon zum
teil als basiert als stärkeren hier
gewählt hat weil er einen punkt machen
wollte nämlich eine erfolgreiche stadt
ist eine stadt wo die bevölkerung und
fahren dass soldaten sich als
geschwister betrachten
wo sonst finden wir diese behauptung
also die behauptung dass die soldaten in
einer stadt erfolgreich sind wenn sie
sich als geschwister sehen in der
politik platons und zwar genau in der
passage wo platon argumentiert dass
soldaten und philosophen auch weiblich
sein können
also diese verbindung zwischen stadt als
familie und frau als lehrerin oder
philosophen ist gab ich für platon die
thematisch wichtig und deswegen denke
ich dass der nächsten interessanten
hintergrund bietet für diese bestattung
der frauen in der politik aber auch für
die optima die weibliche sprecherin die
am ende des symposiums zuvorkommt und
das werde ich nächste woche besprechen
hat jemand fragen zum nexus bevor wir
gehen
sie waren einfach gehen ob
also die erste die wir haben sind von
platon und andere aber nicht nur sondern
aus seinem general seiner generation
ich glaube das hat mir mit soccer teams
zu tun also die wollten schildern wie
wie es war
im sommer dieses kreis zu sein und sie
haben immer durch diese hin und her
argumente sind sie vorgegangen so haben
sie philosophiert und diese so kritiker
wollten das irgendwie verkörpern oder
darstellen
und deswegen haben sie dialoge geschehen
denke ich